welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and the Flash got nuts with
multiversal Insanity that we knew would
be part of this movie when Keaton and
Affleck showed up in trailers but we
didn't know they'd mean everybody hey
spoiler one before I continue I am going
to break down what happens in the final
sequence of this movie in the shocking
DC cameos that appear also please
support our Network by subscribing to
this channel subscribe to the Deep dive
channel for our Spielberg summer slate
into the break room for instant
reactions to all this great stuff and
you can support us with an indie I love
you shirt at nerdright.shop okay when
Barry starts the Flash Film he begins in
the universe of the DC EU as we've known
it Ben Affleck is Batman Jeremy Irons is
Alfred pennyworth Gal Gadot cameos as
Wonder Woman and on a TV news screen
showing the volcanic eruption in
Guatemala you can see Superman
presumably Henry Cavill Superman saving
the day but we only see him from behind
and at a distance but then Barry
accidentally runs faster than the speed
of light and stumbles into what he later
dubs the Chrono Bowl so what the hell is
a Chrono Bowl the Chrono Bowl is this
film's new visual representation of time
travel in multiversal navigation the a
kind of time Coliseum that depicts an
array of moments across Barry's timeline
that he could peer into revisit and
change functionally it's similar to the
Tesseract and Christopher Nolan's
Interstellar but contained within the
concentric circles of an arena as
opposed to the angular corners of a
bookcase aesthetically it creates the
effect of placing Barry on a kind of
performative or academic stage while
also making his disruption to this
timeline a kind of Ground Zero epicenter
structurally and Visually I think it's a
pretty cool concept I just like that
this movie conceived of a new way to
show the Multiverse other than the
glowing snaking sacred timeline and
branches that we see in the MCU or even
the red angular webs that we just saw in
Sony's animated spider-verse I will say
it's a little odd for these vignettes to
have an artificial rubbery look I assume
it was by Design so that to bury these
were all representations of moments to
revisit a kind of clockwork as opposed
to actual corporeal clones at this
moment in space and time right now so
after Barry Alters history so that his
mother Nora won't die when Barry goes
back into the crota bowl to see his life
altering there are some cameos Henry
Cavill Gal Gadot Wonder Woman Ben
Affleck Batman Jason Momoa Aquaman we
seem to be seeing the heroes Park fight
from Justice League the Snyder cup of
the Justice League no other version of
this movie ever happened and so this
establishes the Chrono Bowl as a
historical timeline as seen from this
Barry Allen's eyes in the DC EU in
particular so later in the film Barry
and the younger Berry return to the
Chrono Bowl to replay the events of the
desert battle against Zod to try to
change things so that Michael Keaton
Batman and Supergirl won't die they find
themselves unable to avoid the fates for
those too this video is sponsored by
Electronic Arts so much of modern nerdum
has the Lord of the Rings in its DNA and
now you can have it on your phone with
the Lord of the Rings Heroes of middle
Earth the Lord of the Rings Heroes of
Middle Earth is a new crpg from Capital
games and EA unless you collect your
favorite characters good and evil and
explore Middle Earth you can relive your
favorite stories or experience brand new
ones based on tolkien's works this month
here's Middle Earth is introducing
legendary Adventures limited time events
that give players an opportunity to
upgrade the characters they already have
and unlock powerful new legendary
characters like elrond prepare yourself
for his arrival by collecting five Elven
characters before his legendary
Adventure event starts June 26th elrond
is an incredibly wise and resourceful
Immortal being with a ton of magical
skills and once he shows up he'll be the
strongest healer in Heroes of Middle
Earth plus he's got a multi-target
cinematic attack so he's super fun to
play with legendary Adventures May
return in the future but are only
available for a short time so make sure
to be prepared with your five elves but
hey if you miss elrond's legendary
Adventure event don't stress about it
there are still tons of exciting Lord of
the Rings characters to collect and
stories to explore download Lord of the
Rings Heroes of Middle Earth for free
using the link in the description or by
skating in the QR code with your phone
this leads to a debate between the
berries and the return of dark flash we
find out is actually younger Berry in
the distant future after a lifetime
trying to reset the timeline to save
Kara and Batman but mostly just Kara and
yeah probably his mom too but this has
led to a rupture in the timeline
structural damage to the Chrono Bowl
which splits open to reveal other
chronable spheres and this is meant to
look like the infinite Earths of the DC
Multiverse because the truly was DC
Comics from The Flash even that first
explored the Multiverse in comic book
fiction long before Marvel ever thought
about this with the whole concept of
Earth 2 and then so on it usually takes
the form of alternate Global spheres
alongside our Earth as it does here now
each of these spheres contains some
insane cameos dating back to the
beginning of DC movie history starting
with George Reeves Superman from the 50s
TV series Adventures of Superman now an
unkitty bit of trivia here George Reeves
was later portrayed by Ben Affleck in
the 2006 film hollywoodland which
included one of the tensest moments in
any movie I've ever seen a real life
incident that George Reeves went through
can I shoot you I'm kidding
why would you want to do something like
that so the ball bounces off can I if
you did shoot me
and the bullet bounced off it might
accidentally hit someone else
we don't want that to happen do we no we
see that George Reeve Superman is an
incredible of his own with the stands
filled with the block-headed robot from
season 1 episode 17 of that series The
Runaway robot and then at the center of
that Chrono bowl is an alternate flash
running in place Jay Garrick played by
Teddy Sears from the CW Flash series
when he played Jay Garrick from Earth 3
with that Crimson Comet helmet it is a
little odd that we didn't see John
Wesley's ship who played the Earth 2
Flash Jay garrig in the series after he
originally played The Flash in the CBS
Series in the early 90s but then we zoom
over to a blue sphere where we see the
late Christopher Reeve Superman
recreated with CGI and at his side
Supergirl from the 1984 film played by
Helen Slater they both look into a rift
in the sky at the other spheres Beyond
then a golden sphere showing the late
Adam West Batman and I think behind him
you could see his retro 60s Batmobile
and then a green colored sphere with
Nicholas Cage Superman long hair that
same chesty v-neck suit that he wore in
the 90s Tim Burton wardrobe test for
Superman lives and he's fighting a giant
spider so what's the deal with the
spider this actually came from Kevin
Smith's wild story for when he was hired
to write a script for this movie and
producer John Peters who was Barbara
Streisand's former hairdresser who
somehow got the rights to Superman in
the early 90s this guy was actually
depicted by Bradley Cooper in the film
licorice pizza by the way producer John
Peters had some demands for Kevin Smith
for the way he would write Superman he's
gone three things okay I said all right
one I don't want to see him in that suit
two I don't want to see him fly
and three he's got to fight a giant
spider in the third Act
hahaha
and allegedly this is why the John
Peters produced Wild Wild West ends with
a random giant robot spider and what I
love the most about this is Nick Cage is
Superman fighting the spider it's
actually pretty sick Annie machietti and
his team turn Kevin Smith's jokey story
about John Peter's crazy pitch into an
actual legit proof of concept that
wouldn't look that unusual in a modern
superhero movie in one sequence this
Flash movie gives us a lesson in
Hollywood history and all the odd twists
and turns these DC Legends have taken to
bring us to this point which of course
sets up perfectly for George Clooney
showing up as Barry's new universe Bruce
Wayne in the final moments Bruce Wayne
from the Batman movie even George
Clooney himself disavowed gets to have a
bit of redemption here now was it a
little unsettling to see the ghostly
presence of Christopher Reeve
resurrected with VFX to react to this
moment as opposed to just archival
footage of him doing his thing from one
of his films yeah yeah I think it kind
of was but whatever I can get over it I
think the people who are angriest about
this are the people who went into this
movie looking for reasons to be mad at
it and this is one of many things
they're latching onto really I think the
coolest thing about the circular design
in the Chrono bowls is that from the
outside they actually kind of look like
spools of film strip Celluloid all
bundled up so it looks like we're
looking back into film history and while
I don't think this means an actual
crossover between these realities
anytime soon it does leave the DCU with
a strong visual representation of its
Multiverse that grounds it in the medium
of Cinema and hopefully this inspires
younger DC fans out there to look back
at the older eras that paved the way for
this one please subscribe to the Deep
dive and in the break room and subscribe
to this Channel and you can support us
by grabbing some merch at nerdright.shop
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at a
boss follow new rockstars and be sure to
check out all of our great content for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you